bien merci monsieur le Président on
attaque dans le vif du sujet en ce qui
concerne notre stratégie d'emploi des
seniors là
cet amendement porte sur les seniors au
chômage 2 milliards consacrés par
lunédique pour les chômeurs de plus de
60 ans ça doit quelque part nous
interpeller donc ce qui veut dire que
les outils actuels d'emploi des seniors
ne sont pas suffisants c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons sur proposition
de longues de partenaires sociaux
proposés ce CDI senior le CDI senior
c'est quoi c'est un CDI différent
réservé un contrat entre le salarié et
son employeur pour que on définisse les
conditions de travail le les durées de
travail pour aller jusqu'au taux plein
de départ en retraite du salarié le taux
plein voulant dire être acquis à la fois
par les nombres de trimestres ou
éventuellement avec l'âge d'annulation
de la décote c'est tout à fait différent
de ce qui existe actuellement puisque
les CDI classique peuvent toujours être
utilisés mais sont pas suffisants
puisque on constate que il y a
effectivement un taux de chômage aux
alentours de la soixantaine qui est
particulièrement important c'est pour ça
qu'on veut se doter d'outils nouveaux
pour inciter pour inciter l'employeur
nous proposons une exonération de
cotisation familiales de façon à ce
qu'il y ait une incitation à aller
plutôt sur ce CDI très spécifique
négocié avec le salarié par rapport à
ces traditionnel et pour le salarié ça
me paraît intéressant puisque on adapte
les conditions de travail en fonction
effectivement de son âge ou des
phénomènes d'usure c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce CDI peut être dès à présent
me semble-t-il inscrit dans la loi et je
ne vous demande de le soutenir de façon
à ce qu'ensuite et c'est notre
préoccupation il soit discuté avec les
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre des
négociations pour qu'il puisse être
adopté prise en main par les partenaires
sociaux je vous remercie
[Musique]